the sound of severed Donetsk being
pounded and broken by bombs never stops
Ukrainian troops are vastly outnumbered
here can see the Russians blasting their
way in
and underneath all these explosions
there are civilians still trying to
survive
one of the main Bridges linking the city
to the rest of the dombas has been
bombed it's now impossible
so the only way people can now leave an
aid can get in is on this last usable
Bridge which has been hit several times
already
this is the city's remaining lifeline
and the ukrainians are only just holding
on to it
if there is a humanitarian disaster
rapidly unfolding with thousands of
people still here
this is a city which Russia would have
banked on being pro-kremlin with strong
links and often with relatives living
there they are very reluctant evacuees
but they are fleeing in the face of this
terrible onslaught
hell you know it's hell uh first uh
everyday
second a lot of them third humanitarian
problems
the sole working hospital is now
surrounded by Russian troops so the only
chance to be injured is to be evacuated
and this is one of the very few
evacuation trips
now it seems like the front is all
around the city
we can see uh trucks from the Army being
being deployed around the city so it
seems very clear that to me it's about
to fall are you glad to be going yes
yes and no
um I don't know feeling sad about
leaving as well
but time is running out of there to
leave
and these volunteers hope to be back
later to help more flee
a handful are delivering water strapping
bottles on the back of their bikes to
take to those trapped in their homes
joke
he was a musician once
now his world is filled with the sounds
of War
a small moment to collect himself
but we will win he tells us
everything will be okay
thank you he says and kisses my hand
there's work to do
Valerie is another it's far away he
reassures us about the bombing the
strength of these people continues to
astonish
ing it doesn't even Flinch so yeah
without any jobs
we're used to it he says it's been three
months
Valerian his wife Nila won't leave
they've notched up 135 years between
them and they're now enduring bombs
which are landing every few minutes
foreign
it is unrelenting and goes on and on as
he weaves his way back through his
community and takes us to his home where
he and his neighbors have been
Sheltering and where he's been ferrying
food and water to where there seems to
be still a fair amount of people living
up his neighbors tell us how hard it is
to get even water
Elena's saying she has to carry two or
three bottles by hand
[Music]
everyone begins to panic at what sounds
like cluster bombs Landing far too close
by we head for the doorway to shelter
y shouts come come he says I'm used to
it everyone piles inside waiting for yet
more incoming bombs
Selena tells us it was quiet for just 10
minutes every day it's back and forth
like this flying over our heads
seconds later Valeria is punched by a
neighbor he's angry at Valeri for
bringing foreign journalists here many
blame us for prompting the bombings
this war has set pensioner against
pensioner and forced neighbors to turn
on each other
please tell the world what's happening
in donbass she says
and show please how it is
I'm trying not to cry she says I'm
trying to keep myself calm but you need
to tell them what the situation is
well this is going on all the time
constant barrage it's unbelievable that
there are so many people who are still
living and having to put up with this
they're right in the middle of it
at the aid Hub more injured have been
brought in and one woman has got a very
nasty head wound there's no gunshot
wound it's just a shrapnel the worst
injuries to her head but she just needs
to get evacuated for that
it turns out Sky News colleague Nick
Davenport is the most qualified medic
here probably in the whole of the city
there's a police trained first aider too
who asked not to be identified
there are two badly wounded here but
most certainly not the only ones in dire
need of medical health in the city
Emma is back with her Evac team but her
vehicle has broken down so she's
urgently trying to find replacements
passenger vehicles
somehow the aid Hub manager finds a way
out for them
this is going to be a difficult and
dangerous Journey for them but at least
they have hope there's very little of
that going around this city right now as
the Russian troops pose in Alex Crawford
Sky News in several of the Mets in
eastern Ukraine
all right